madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal nous antilles la guadeloupe se
barricade dans la tente du l'ouragan
george hill pourrait passer au large de
l'île cette nuit est touché de plein
fouet antigua après la décision du
conseil régional de l'ordre de relaxer à
médecin ayant pratiqué l'euthanasie le
débat sur la mort douce et réouvert
invités de ce journal le secrétaire
d'état à la santé bernard kouchner
la voiture de l'an 2000 elle
fonctionnera par reconnaissance vocale
outre mondiale obéira à la voix de son
maître
une petite révolution théâtre avec
variations énigmatiques après le
triomphe il ya deux ans elle a de longs
reprend cette pièce d'éric emmanuel
schmitt à ses côtés stéphane freiss j'ai
le plaisir de les accueillir tous les
deux ce soir sur notre plateau aux états
unis ce dimanche matin de prière fut
l'occasion pour la droite religieuse
américaine de dénoncer une nouvelle fois
l'attitude du président américain à
moins de 24 heures de la diffusion
télévisée du témoignage de bill clinton
les médias publient déjà quelques bribes
de la déposition devant le grand jury
philippe gassot pour transmettre les
images du président à l'amérique les
grandes télévisions qui font partie du
pool de la maison blanche recevront en
même temps à 9 heures lundi matin les
quatre heures d'enregistrement de la
déposition présidentielle les images
arriveront dans les rédactions par
satellite au départ du congrès
chacun traitera les documents à sa
manière par extraits ou en totalité
cnn ou la fox vont diffuser
l'enregistrement brut sans coupure sans
publicité avec un avertissement pour les
enfants l'événement médiatique
historique qui se prépare ne semble pas
avoir prise sur le président clinton qui
se rend à la messe il veut montrer que
sa vie de président continue
le grand choc des images annoncé ne
paraît pas troubler outre mesure les
américains week-end qui ont choisi de se
détendre entre maison blanche et congrès
allez vous regarder les bandes vidéo
non ça m'intéresse pas du tout non non
j'en ai vu assez sur internet j'en ai
assez entendu incidemment savard je ne
crois pas que c'est à 100% le rôle des
américains mais je vais faire comme tout
le monde je vais regarder sur le môle la
promenade des américains on rencontre
plutôt des hommes et des femmes étonnée
par l'explosion médiatique de la faire
il semble cependant encore très nombreux
à défendre le président je pense qu'il
fait du bon boulot et je ne fais aucun
commentaire sur la vie privée de qui que
ce soit je crois qu'il est vraiment
temps maintenant qu'ils s'en aillent
il est temps que ce pays grand 10h le
scandale clinton n'empêche pas les
américains de venir ici profiter de
leurs derniers week ends d'été dans une
prospérité qu'ils savent de voir au
moins en partie à l'actuel locataire de
la maison blanche
la guadeloupe dans la tente du cyclone
les vents se sont considérablement
renforcées ces dernières heures
désormais les rafales atteignent près de
300 km/heure les premiers effets ont
touché l'île de la désirade à l'est de
cette région des antilles selon la
trajectoire de l'ouragan susceptibles de
changer de cap à chaque instant c'est
l'île d'antigua qui devrait être la
cible bertrand cocq voici le visage de
george photographier ce matin par le
satellite de météo france une énorme
masse nuageuse de 800 kilomètres de
diamètre
dans quelques heures le cyclone qui
draine dans ses plis des vents de 250
km/heure atteindra le nord de la
guadeloupe frappant de plein fouet les
îles du vent antigua montserrat st
martin promise aux rafales les plus
fortes
cet après midi les premières pluies
annonciatrice d'orage plus violents ont
trempé la guadeloupe et le nord de la
martinique
les guadeloupéens ont passé les
dernières heures à se barricader avec
des gestes qui révèle une vieille
habitude on a coupé cloué calfeutrer
portes et fenêtres avant de s'enfermer
chez soi
en vertu du plan orsec cyclone toute
circulation est interdite à pied en
voiture ou à vélo des recommandations
superflu en attendant georges tout le
monde ici se souvient de la visite de
son cousin hugo en 89 26 morts dont 15
en guadeloupe
vingt mille sinistrés et des millions de
francs de dégâts et nous rejoignent et
en direct de la guadeloupe jean philippe
pascal bonsoir vous êtes rédacteur en
chef à rfo à combien de kilomètres de
lille précisément se situe désormais
l'ouragan
écoutez béatrice se nouera dont georges
se trouve désormais à 300 km à l'est de
la guadeloupe c'est un cyclone
dévastateur puissant de très forte
intensité et les classé en catégorie 4
par les spécialistes de météo france
autrement dit nous raconte d'anjou avec
des vents moyenne de l'ordre de 240 km
heure et des rafales approchant les 300
km heure c'est une masse nuageuse
on l'a dit tout à l'heure
impressionnante avec un diamètre
d'environ 800 km il faut dire que ce
cyclone le septième de la saison a
ralenti sa vitesse et dans le même temps
il s'est légèrement renforcé le centre
de l'ouragan devrait passer
principalement au nord de la guadeloupe
peut ce soir mais l'ensemble de
l'archipel restent concernés béatrice
par le phénomène cyclonique et on l'a
compris évidemment l attente et
l'inquiétude grandit d'heure en heure
vous allez bientôt passer en alerte 3
alors pour l'instant la guadeloupe est
placé en alerte de renforcer autrement
dit aucune circulation les habitants
sont invités à rester chez eux
mais la population se prépare à vivre ce
cyclone avec une certaine anxiété dans
la mesure où elles restent encore
traumatisés par le souvenir du cyclone
hugo c'était en 1989 cet ouragan était
d'une rare violence il avait provoqué
des dégâts matériels importants et des
morts et on a peur ici que les mêmes
effets se produise même si tout est fait
prêt pour limiter bien évidemment au
maximum les effets dévastateurs de
georges merci de toutes ces précisions
au chapitre politique que le premier
tour des élections législatives
partielles à toulon pour la troisième
fois en 16 mois les électeurs se sont
rendus aux urnes à 17 heures la
participation avoisinait 34% en légère
baisse par rapport
les tours d'avril dernier michaël darmon
vous êtes en direct j'espère de toul an
quel est le taux définitif de
participation est conne et ont déjà les
premières tendances de cette élection
qui va se jouer au coude à coude
ah oui béatrice le taux de participation
était à 19h de 43% encore plus faible
lors du dernier scrutin
et cette forte abstention illustre bien
la lassitude constaté durant la campagne
cette campagne qui je vous le rappelle
était donc la 3e en 15 mois pour l'heure
les résultats que nous avons sur sept
mille bulletins dépouillés transmis par
la préfecture
les scores sont très serrés puisque
sandrine chevalier la candidate fn
obtient 39,22 % des voix odette casanova
la candidate de la gauche plurielle
contient 37,91 % des voix
quant au candidat rpr udf marc bell il
obtient 21 15% des voix
vous voyez entre les deux candidates
donc le score est très serré mais d'ores
et déjà on peut dire que con ça lance
pour le deuxième tour vers un duel ps fn
merci michael darmon dans son discours
de clôture de la fête des bleu blanc
rouge jean marie le pen en appel aux
militants pour qu'ils viennent le plus
nombreux possible ou procès qui doit se
tenir à la fin du mois devant la cour de
versailles en jeu sa possible la
validation pour les prochaines élections
européennes
par ailleurs le président du front
national compte s'attaquer au traité
d'amsterdam arnaud bouter yves janka
la messe dominicale rendez vous
obligatoire des catholiques du front
national l'occasion une nouvelle fois de
présenter l'image d'une famille
politique unie la brouille estivale
entre jean marie le pen et bruno mégret
est close
il n'y a qu'un seul chef bruno mégret
l'a compris ses sympathisants également
aux européennes ils voteront pour le
parti quel que soit le candidat soit
jany le pen ou bruno mégret vous savez
est égale absolument pas différencie pas
d'écart mais avec la candidature de jany
le pen certains sortent des rangs
ils marquent leur position ou leur
satisfaction bruno mégret devrait
conduire la liste aux européennes si ce
n'est pas jean-marie le pen tracy carlos
et tous militants impliqués au front
national vous dira la même chose
aujourd'hui quel est le meilleur
candidat pour les européennes jean marie
le pen jany le pen ou bruno mégret
témoin j'ai tendance comme je le sens de
la boutade à dire que c'est jany le pen
dans son discours de clôture jean marie
le pen a soigneusement évité toute
polémique le futur candidat du front
national aux européennes défendre à
l'europe des nations
nous allons tout au long des mois qui
nous séparent de l'élection de juin
mobiliser les français pour tenter
d'arracher la france à l'europe de
maastricht de schengen et d'amsterdam à
l'europe fédérale a servi au lobby au
grand capitalisme financier au cnom
anonyme de francfort et de wall street
et comme invité d'honneur à la tribune
il y avait je nie que jean marie le pen
impose de plus en plus sur la scène
politique
le président de démocratie libérale à la
madelin dans les bouches du rhône pour
la fête départementale de sa formation
l'occasion de clarifier sa position
vis-à-vis du front national car le
comment bruno niver taux affichés ce la
bonne humeur
voilà qui semble faire partie des bonnes
résolutions de la droite pour cette
rentrée est là maintenant on a voulu
faire preuve de la sienne aujourd'hui à
la fête de son parti organisé dans les
bouches-du-rhône démocratie libérale
avait défrayé la chronique cet été après
l'adhésion de jacques blanc et son
groupe parlementaire
alain madelin a tenté de mettre un point
final à la polémique en clarifiant sa
position face au front national sur un
mode offensif
nous savons très bien à qui profite le
front national entre nous entre françois
hollande et bruno mégret j'ai un peu le
sentiment parfois que c'est passe moi le
sel je te passerai le poivre voilà
pourquoi je dis tranquillement à ses
donneurs de leçons qu'ils gardent leurs
leçons
en ce qui nous concerne nous combattons
le front national mais nous entendons
bien le faire à notre façon accusée
d'entretenir l'ambiguïté par ses alliés
du rpr et de l'udf
alain madelin tente donc aussi de
rassurer jusqu'à ses propres amis faire
jouer la même partition à l'ensemble de
l'opposition
c'est apparemment une autre des bonnes
résolutions de la droite vers cette
rentrée
pour la première fois une instance
médicale celle du conseil régional de
l'ordre des médecins décident de ne pas
poursuivre l'un de ses membres pour
euthanasie active pour l'instant on
ignore s'il y aura des poursuites
pénales mais cette affaire dont nous
rendions compte hier soir ouvre à
nouveau le débat sur la peine sur la
mort douce il nous en discuterons dans
un instant avec bernard kouchner qui est
notre invité lui d'abord le rappel des
faits cet homme a accompagné dans la
mort une vieille dame de 92 ans
hémiplégique souffrent de gangrène est
plongé dans le coma en concertation avec
l'équipe médicale mais sans avoir averti
la famille le docteur jean-paul dufault
a agi en conscience il à administrer une
piqûre de pelures de potassium à sa
patiente un acte réfléchi un acte
illégal
et pourtant ses pairs ont refusé de le
sanctionner une décision dont peut faire
appel le conseil national de l'ordre des
médecins qui a récemment réaffirmé sa
position entre l'euthanasie active
médecin doit accompagner le mourant
jusqu'à ses derniers moment assuré par
des soins et mesures appropriées la
qualité d'une vie qui prend fin
sauvegarder la dignité du malade et
réconforter son entourage il n'a pas le
droit de provoquer délibérément la mort
l'euthanasie une question morale auquel
le corps médical est constamment
confronté en 1990 le professeur léon
schwartzenberg avait été suspendu un an
par le conseil de l'ordre
le cancérologue avait laissé entendre sa
participation active à une euthanasie
d'une personne désespérée
vous restez un médecin technicien où
vous devenez un être humain décider de
la vie ou de la mort d'un malade
incurable et qui souffre
un débat qui divise position de l'église
par rapport à la vie et est claire je
crois que quelques puces est le débat
pour l'église la vie est sacrée
au début comme à son terme et il
n'appartient pas à un être humain de
décider de disposer de la vie de notre
nom je pense que ça doit rester une
transgression et que la loi ne doit pas
être modifié en autorisant l'euthanasie
actuellement le code pénal à 6000
l'euthanasie un homicide volontaire à un
meurtre
faut-il changer la loi faut-il légiférer
sur la mort faut-il oui ou
non aider les personnes qui le
souhaitent à mourir avec ce qu'il leur
reste deux plus beaux la dignité dans un
conteneur
bonsoir je voudrais d'abord vous poser
quelques questions simples
je m'adresse non pas l'homme politique
nos médecins est ce que ce soit vous
pourriez être vous cet homme ce médecin
qui a été relaxé est ce que pour y être
à sa place
oui oui en effet il m'est arrivé d'être
confrontés à des situations comme
celle-là pour moi la décision fut plus
collectif peut-être merci de cette
franchise
une autre question tout aussi direct nul
ne sait s'il y aura des poursuites
pénales
mais qu'adviendra-t-il à ce médecin
apparemment l'hôpital attend une réponse
du ministère est ce qu'il va être
réintégré dans son service est ce qu'il
va être muté
ce qui va être envoyée nous fournirons
cette réponse je crois légitime de
peut-être lui permettre de travailler
dans un autre contexte mais en même
temps de ne pas le sanctionner
c'est très clair autre question là aussi
tout aussi claire on ne sait pas si le
conseil de l'ordre va faire appel de la
décision de ce conseil de l'ordre
régionales mais que dites vous aux
professeurs glorian qui dirige le
conseil de l'ordre que lui dit vous et
que répondez-vous lorsqu'il vous
reproche d'avoir parlé d'un acte de
charité
je lui reproche de faire semblant de ne
pas comprendre
j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour lui je
pense que il est responsable de la
déontologie je comprends très bien est
ce qu'il a lu tout à l'heure bien sûr
nous sommes les médecins en charge de la
vie pas de la mort met les choses au
change et l'évolution des temps les
équipes la fin de vie ce très beau mot
d'accompagnement je crois qu'il faut
débattre de tout cela je souhaite
personnellement mais je n'ai aucun
conseil à donner à bernard blot riant
qu'il n'y ait pas d'appel mais qu on
puisse débattre
c'est un débat très difficile mais
toutes les opinions
je les ai entendues elles sont
respectables parlons-en
il s'agit toujours de soi même de ses
parents de son amour justement est ce qu
a pas une énorme hypocrisie des
instances politiques morales religieuses
médical qui
est-ce au fond dans un désarroi énorme
le personnel soignant qui lui est
confrontée au quotidien et les familles
à ce drame de la vie on nous répète
depuis des années qu'il faut débattre et
depuis des années on observe les mêmes
drames oui vous avez raison il ya
beaucoup d'hypocrisie trop d'hypocrisie
mais d'abord le débat aura lieu il
commence dans les états généraux
maintenant dans les jours qui viennent
je souhaite qu'il y ait de plus de débat
possible autour non pas d'euthanasie
oublions ce mot horrible mais de la fin
de vie de l'accompagnement de l'équipe
de la tendresse de la manière dont
ensemble nous pouvons prendre en charge
nos amis nos parents nos frères
deuxièmement la loi c'est pas simple
vous savez personnellement je crois
qu'il ne faut pas légiférer ou alors
peut-être se pencher sur le cas des
poursuites pour les uns ou pour les
autres mais légiférer c'est quoi ces
froidement déterminer à quel moment on
va agir non c'est pas ça je ne crois pas
il y aura encore sans hypocrisie
quelques cas de ce genre mais si les
soins palliatifs comme je souhaite sont
distribués à travers le pays ce qui est
loin d'être le cas que de promesses ça
fait combien d'années qu'on répète en
effet qu'il faut lutter contre la
douleur qu'il faut multiplier les soins
palliatifs qu'il faut des équipes
mobiles vous le dites d'autres l'ont dit
avant vous voyez quand jose enflammés et
vous avez raison
oui moi je crois et je ne crache pas je
ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé avant je
sais ce qui s'est passé avant il ya eu
des progrès en france il y aura de
l'argent je serai peut-être demain ou
après demain combien pour les soins
palliatifs la douleur est prise en
charge pour la première fois il n'y aura
plus de carnet à souches pour la
première fois ses infirmières dont vous
avez raison de parler et qui sont
souvent les plus isolés à prendre des
responsabilités et à contempler la
souffrance pourront elles mêmes en tout
cas gommer au maximum la souffrance sans
qu'on cherche le médecin à l'intérieur
de l'hôpital
il y à une formation qui doit être fait
on n'apprend pas à comment dirais-je
supprimer la souffrance au contraire
dans notre école de clinique
on l'entendait on l'attendait comme un
signe tout ça va disparaître
il faut du temps oui j'espère en tout
cas c'est ma volonté très forte celle du
gouvernement ont pris acte ce soir
peut-être pourrait revenir dans quelques
mois pour faire le premier bilan six
pieds au c est là parce que nous ferons
rien sans l'opinion mais blé on y
participe sur trois étages et médias ou
l'amour ça font énormément leur travail
j'en suis sûr messi se débattre ensemble
nous débattons de ce sujet alors cela
deviendra un sujet majeur et nous
pourrons prendre des décisions plus
facilement tout autre sujet dans le
domaine de la haute technologie je vous
propose de découvrir ce système
révolutionnaire en cours
d'expérimentation la reconnaissance
vocale pour téléphoner changer la
température ambiante ou la station de
radio de votre voiture
le tout bien sûr sans lâcher le volant
luc besson frédéric de la rue cette
voiture a une relation privilégiée avec
son conducteur
elle écoute le comprend et lui obéit
c'est l'hypothèse fort
une pulsion sur ce bouton placé sur le
volant et ça y est la voiture est allée
coûte les mains sur le volant et le
regard fixé sur la route
il s'agit en fait d'un élément de
sécurité il sera monté en série sur
certaines voitures dès l'année prochaine
est disponible en français dès l'année
suivante face à nice systems deux
premières générations reconnaît jusqu'à
deux mille maux pour le moment et on
sera bien sûr capable d'effectuer encore
davantage de fonctions comme ouvrir les
portes ou les fenêtres mais ce qu'on
veut c'est introduire ce système tout de
suite auprès de l'utilisateur doucement
tranquillement pour qu'ils s'y habituent
avant de rajouter plus de fonctions à
l'avenir voici ce que le système en
temps sans aucune infiltration une fois
l'écho supprimer le conducteur devient
beaucoup plus audible la reconnaissance
vocale est également en expérimentation
actuellement chez renault voici comment
la machine apprend du vocabulaire
je vais rentrer dans mon moteur de
reconnaissance à nouveau monde donc par
exemple france 2 donc là on à
l'expression politique de france 2 et ça
y est il suffit maintenant de prononcer
le mot france france 2 un logiciel et le
reconnaître france 2 maintenant ils me
demandent le long de la rue boulevard
valin goût
ça y est le système est parti mais la
voiture est guidé jusqu'à jusqu'à france
2 renault devrait proposer ce système
sur ses voitures dès 2001 m france info
l'intelligence de la machine devrait
permettre de répondre aussi bien un
homme qui a une femme et autant à un
marseillais qu'un strasbourgeois
à terme les boutons de plus en plus
nombreux sur les tableaux de bord
deviendront superflu et pourront donc
totalement disparaître à l'étranger en
afghanistan bombardements meurtriers sur
kaboul un missile le troisième de la
journée tirée par l'opposition anti
taliban a touché de plein fouet a marché
de la capitale au moins 100 morts et de
très nombreux blessés qui s'ajoutent aux
victimes de la matinée les élections
parlementaires en suède les
sociaux-démocrates semble bien assurée
de conserver le pouvoir avec le soutien
attendu des ex communistes du parti de
la gauche 6 millions et demi d'inscrits
pour cette élection des 349 députés
après l'entrée en vigueur de la trêve
illimitée décidée par le thé à
l'organisation séparatiste armée le
président du gouvernement espagnol josé
maria aznar a réuni son gouvernement ce
matin de nombreuses consultations
devraient suivre auprès des principaux
leaders pour connaître précisément leurs
positions mais tant dans la classe
politique que sur le terrain au pays
basque c'est le scepticisme qui prévaut
philippe visseyrias jean yves blein
marché dans les rues de san sebastien
pouvoir se mêler aux promeneurs sans
craindre le pire avant la trêve tout
cela était interdit ramon gomez
ce jeune conseiller municipal du parti
populaire et menacée de mort par le tf
depuis un an il ne dort pas de nuit au
même endroit et en dépit du cessez le
feu
son garde du corps ne le lâche pas d'une
semelle 24 heures sur 24
ramon gomez entama lent retour à la vie
normale même si pour lui la paix n'est
encore qu'un rêve lointain
le ter a tué près de 900 personnes en 30
ans et là ils disent qu'ils arrêtent de
tuer moi je le croirai vraiment quand
ils rendront les arbres quand le 26
octobre prochain au lendemain des
élections au pays basque ils diront nous
maintenons la trêve nous voulons parler
disent négocier négocier eux n'avaient
jamais voulu en entendre parler
nous sommes à bilbao dans un meeting
organisé par les familles des membres de
letea emprisonner les slogans n'ont pas
changé
bora et amélie tard à vivre l'hôtel
militaire mais au-delà de cette mise en
scène
les militants sont divisés
nous devons aboutir à un accord qui soit
favorable par tous je pense parce que ça
suffit comme ça un peuple a le droit
d'utiliser tous les moyens à sa
disposition pour obtenir sans
souveraineté ou les moyens
tous les moyens trop souvent cela fut le
meur arantxa chat un bar dans la
banlieue de bilbao
en 1991 un attentat de l'ôter a tué son
fils de deux ans ont bien un jour vous
pourrez pardonner non jamais pourquoi
ils m'ont pris quelqu'un de cher
quelqu'un qu'il n'avait pas le droit
d'un médecin
entre rennes et attentisme la société
basque n'ose pas croire à la paix mais
ce week-end dans les rues de san
sebastien les drapeaux irlandais
côtoient les drapeaux basques comme un
exemple à suivre
une véritable réussite pour ces journées
du patrimoine davantage encore de
visiteurs que les années précédentes
11 millions et demi de français ont
parcouru les différents sites un peu
partout c'est rare dalmaz et france
bayonne nous feront partager l'un des
prix aux gagnants
curieusement c'est au palais royal qui
est logé le gardien de la république
conseil constitutionnel mission veiller
au fonctionnement des institutions
contrôlées élections et loi d'ailleurs
voici le bureau du président actuel
roland dumas et pendant qu'on est dans
l'autorité le solennel voici le salon
bleu c'est ici que le nom du nouveau
président de la république est proclamée
beaucoup plus qu aux ors et aux décors
le visiteur s'intéresse au rôle du
conseil souvent si le secrétaire général
qui fait le guide
l'immense majorité des questions porte
précisément sur le fonctionnement des
institutions et des personnages qu'on
veut encore les bureaux chargés de
dossiers
impuissante
quand l'esprit des gens qui travaillent
après le saint des saints républicain
direction le parvis de saint sulpice
village des métiers installé par la
drague d'île de france une première ici
des artisans 33 spécialité font la
démonstration d'un talent admirable se
mettant de plus en plus souvent au
service de la restauration des monuments
et objets d'art savoir faire qui redonne
du lustre au travail manuel
on dit qu'on va pas jusqu'à discuter au
cas ça qu'on devrait orienter les jeunes
vers ces métiers là sont des métiers
d'avenir et qui ont une valeur vraiment
réel
12 juillet dernier devant le gratin des
gradins la planète football tombe en
pâmoison la france triomphe au stade de
france alors pendant ce week-end
patrimoniale mais en payant des milliers
de fans de téléspectateurs sont venus
visiter le temple du sacre des bleus
la piste géante des rolling stones ce la
scène des mesures et des concerts de
johnny mais cet après midi certains
visiteurs se serait bien vu en short
bleu sur la pelouse verte
record battu en une soirée de juillet le
stade de france est devenu un lieu de
mémoire pour le monde entier
théâtre à présent j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir alain delon et stéphane
freiss bonsoir vous êtes en pleine
répétition de la pièce d'éric emmanuel
schmitt variations énigmatiques que vous
avez interprété alain delon il ya deux
ans que tête francis huster aujourd'hui
l' aventure se poursuit mais avec comme
partenaire stéphane freiss tout de suite
s'il voulait bien ces moments de
répétition au théâtre de paris
c'est la première fois que vous vous
laisser filmer en répétition jean-marc
face à patrick voix je vais leur
demander combien de paris veulent
méticuleux direct un patient alain delon
joue dans variations énigmatiques un
personnage qui ressemble étrangement à
alain delon justement un double
peut-être une sorte de demi frère un
écrivain mondialement connue mais qui a
choisi de vivre tout seul sur une île
reculée à jour on ne sait pas pourquoi
il accepte de rencontrer un journaliste
un journaliste pas très net et non plus
un journaliste qui lui aussi a une idée
derrière la tête
stéphane freiss
et vous arrive là bas ils sont deux et
aucun ne prendra le premier en avant par
les voix de nous marier et à votre femme
les deux hommes ont connu la même femme
ils s'affrontent à battant leurs cartes
et renversant la situation chacun leur
tour mais pas ordinaire non de revenir
les gens pour les accabler qu'est ce que
ça cache
c'était pas facile pour stéphane freiss
d'accepter de jouer avec un phénomène
comme alain delon qui capte l'attention
publique à lui tout seul fraisse à le
muscler le nerf pour envoyer son
partenaire dans les cordes
un duo qui a le bon punch pour faire
vivre la pièce d'éric emmanuel schmitt
évidemment on va on va en parler ça vous
fait quel effet quand vous voyez les
répétitions ce qu'au fond est-ce que
vous allez en terrain connu en terrain
conquis serré puisque cette pièce vous
l'avais joué à là dedans et ça a été un
triomphe où est ce que malgré tout riait
besoin de se surpasser le défi puis le
traduit tout simplement lévy a le besoin
se surpasser ça n'est jamais en terrain
conquis il ya le défi à la volonté de
faire encore mieux et je crois que c'est
ce à quoi nous allons aboutir avec
stéphane et je voudrais vous reprendre
puisque vous avez cité deux fois le mot
trio je vous en remercie je n'aurais pas
osé en parler j'aurais dit que la pièce
a vu un certain que c'était à trier
voilà donc je verrai si je n'avais pas
je n'aurais pas osé le dire
et si cette pièce a été repris je
voudrais juste vous faire un petit
petite parenthèse si cette pièce est et
repris c'est justement suite à ce grand
succès trop de gens nous ont demandé
nous ont dit qu'ils n'avaient pas pu
voir cette pièce qu'il n'y avait pas de
place les gens venaient de l'étranger
venaient de partout en france et à à
cause de cela
gilbert coullier mon producteur et moi
même avons décidé de redonner 80
représentations exceptionnelles de
variations énigmatiques 2 octobre afin à
fin décembre
vous avez joué pendant les 120
représentations il ya deux ans le
personnage d'un homme solitaire proches
de la mort
vous avez donc quitter ce personnage
pendant deux ans avec le recul est-ce
que vous l'abordez aujourd'hui
différemment est-ce que vous lui avez
donné une autre cher est ce qu'il est
plus au diapason de vos sentiments
d'aujourd'hui les deux ont passé lui ont
donné une autre cher je crois qu'il l'a
mûri ce sera probablement bonifier avec
le temps passer mais ces jeux laborde
très difficilement parce que depuis ses
deux ans j'ai complètement oublié par
mon personnage mais disons le texte et
qui à un certain niveau un certain
moment de votre vie le texte est
beaucoup plus difficile à mémoriser que
que l'avant non mais je veux dire avec
le concours de stéphane qui m'aide
énormément je dois z'y va lui poser la
question à stéphane sais pas si vous
aidez alain delon mais ce qu'alain delon
vous a aidé comment vous at il accueilli
sur scène ce qui les patterns avis il
vous a soutenu ou plutôt et vous met à
l'épreuve
écoutez ça va vous surprendre mais ça se
passe pas mal du tout pourquoi cette
femme sans nom mais ce que j'entendais
les commandes à la terre ce que j'écoute
j'entends des commentaires qui ont été
faits ça se passe de mal du tout bon
temps il rugit on l'entend jusqu'à
l'église de la trinité mais après ça va
beaucoup mieux et puis c'est très sain
et puis on a une grande complicité c'est
une pièce qui parle d'amour pièce qui
parle de sentiments il faut être
il faut être généreux et on s'apprécie
on se regarde on échange
vous avez besoin alain delon de cette
force de cette violence de cette
confrontation
ça veut dire de vous oui bien sûr si
vous ne jouez pas tout seul sur scène
est un personnage de cette importance de
cette de ce volume je veux dire ne peut
pas ce ne ne peut pas se priver d'un
personnage d'appartenir la hauteur et je
veux dire que stéphane est là pour ça
dieu merci mais je n'ai pas choisi par
hasard
je voudrais aussi vous dire que si cette
pièce ne l'avons pas dit si cette pièce
a eu le succès que vous avez bien voulu
spécifier c'est parce que c'est une
pièce admirable sur un texte admirable
et ça il faut quand même le dire et
c'est ce que je croise des femmes ne
ressent tous les jours alors peut-être
un petit mot sur des sujets qui peuvent
fâcher
il n'y a pas forcément l'équipe de
l'origine dans cette pièce
en tout cas la mise en scène avec
francis huster je ne sais pas comment se
passe la mise en scène je ne sais pas
quelles sont vos relations avec avec
l'auteur veut et moi je dire francis
huster il est émerveillé il m'a donné
j'ai plaisir à jouer avec lui pendant
pendant la représentation
il a décidé de prendre un autre un autre
chemin je veux dire je remercie ses fans
d'être là donc je ne fais pas si vous
voulez moi j'ai un personnage en face de
moi qui s'appelle larsen bon c'est ça
n'est pas un problème qui est ce que ce
soit stéphane ou francis alors j'ai
peut-être un choix préférentiel ça je
vous le dirai peut-être plus tard mais
en ce qui concerne le reste environ
oui non mais en ce qui concerne le reste
dont la mise en scène c'était exactement
la même je voulais 120 x jeu sa gelée
vraiment dans les jambes c'est clair il
n'est pas fâché avec l'équipe initiale
si vous voulez la vérité je vais vous
révéler où je suis fâché avec l'équipe
initiale mais ça n'a aucun aucun
incident sur la pièce que les gens
viendront voir dans huit jours
d'accord alors autre sujet celui là qui
à mon avis ne devrait pas vous fâcher
mais coïncidence quand même au même
moment il ya deux ans belmondo était à
l'affiché au théâtre
il fera également à la fiche d'adam dans
quelques jours puisqu'il reprend une
pièce également d'eric emmanuel schmitt
qui lui a écrit
coïncidence ou ironie du sort qui lui a
écrit également une pièce du reste sur
mesure d'abord ça vous agace ses
parallèle a pas du tout pas du tout
content et ça motive sa sauce et
d'émulation richer tout à fait surtout
avec un comédien comme jean paul est une
pièce de schmidt que je ne connais pas
ça ne peut que me motiver je ne peux que
me me forcer encore à être allés plus
loin et être meilleur
ce que j'espère je serai qu'est ce que
vous attendez d'une pièce que comme
celle là vous avez dit tout de suite oui
et stéphane freiss quand on vous l'a
proposé où vous avez eu peur de la
réputation et de du caractère d'alain
deux jours si je voulais faire un peu
d'humour je vous dirais que ça va faire
beaucoup de bien ma carrière c'est
absolument pas pour ça que je l'accepté
c'est parce que d'abord la pièce est
somptueuse
le rappeler parce qu'il ya un vrai défi
d'acteur et que et que et que c'est un
c'est pas un combat c'est un nid en
affrontement c'est un ping pong c'est un
échange c'est tout ce travail sur la
sensibilité sur sur la communion et je
dois dire que pour ça on s'entend très
bien
alain delon on connaît tous votre
passion pour la boxe je vous propose de
suivre cette vente aux enchères qui est
inhabituel c'était une surprise mais
demain à l'espace des gens une
soixantaine d'objets ayant appartenu au
boxeur marcel cerdan seront dispersés
c'est son fils qu'a eu l'idée de cette
vente et 50 ans après jour pour jour le
titre de champion du monde de cerdans
florent gautreau michel levasseur le
même visage
les mêmes vieux la même carrure c'est
bien marcel cerdan le fils mais on ne
peut s'empêcher de repenser au père
marcel junior a décidé de réunir une
dernière fois les trésors du champion et
de les vendre aux enchères
médaille short ou photos chacune des 58
pièce évoque un souvenir précis j'étais
vexé vie tant qu'ils m'avaient offert le
short de mon père parce qu'il avait
assisté au championnat du monde de mon
père a new jersey et bien entendu quand
mon père est devenu champion du monde du
poste qu'il a dû se retirer toutes ses
affaires sans faire attention elle a dû
les laisser un petit peu traîné éméché
l'élite avait avait récupéré cette
culotte elle a offert aussi grand que ce
short blanc encore tachés du sang de son
adversaire marcel cerdan le portait à
l'occasion de son championnat du monde
victorieux aux états unis c'était il ya
50 ans jour pour jour face à l'américain
tony zeil
le petit français né au maroc devenez
champion du monde est rentré dans heroes
sur le sol français
la ceinture en or que brandit cerdan
reste la plus belle pièce de la
collection est le symbole marquant que
sa réussite sportive
mais les acheteurs intéressés devront
mettre le prix la ceinture c'est peut
être 100 200 300 mille francs plus
peut-être tout dépendra un petit peu de
qui sera dans la salle
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait unique rarissime et
concernant le plus grand boxeur de tous
les torts en france il suffirait de
briser la glace et chaque relique nous
ramènerait au champion
la bouteille utilisée pour se désaltérer
pendant son championnat du monde
la montre en argent offerte par edith
piaf le short bleu porte bonheur de ses
débuts cerdan et la boxe edith et marcel
les reliques précieuses ou des maîtres
retrace la courte vie du champion mort à
33 ans dans un accident d'avion
cerdan n'est pas mort ces médailles
brille encore
en donnant un mot de réaction vous ces
collectionneurs vous pourriez être
intéressé par une vente comme cela je ne
peux pas répondre parce que sam c'est
une chose qui me touche énormément qui
me bouleverse j'ai peur que qu'on fasse
cette vente des objets personnels de
marcel parce que je crois avoir compris
que la famille avait besoin de l'argent
et moi je ne me sens pas acheter quelque
chose de marseille sait pas vraiment
nous avons usé de les admirer du et
c'est que justement puisque vous avez
admiré mais on a retrouvé un extrait que
je vous propose de regarder où vous
parlait à l'époque avec beaucoup
d'émotion justement de l'accident de
marché le faire dans regardez moi
d'abord j'ai beaucoup pleuré je crois
que nous étions nombreux à pleurer la
mort de certains disparition marcel
cerdan
et m'en souviens très bien si c'est en
1949 à l'automne je prends septembre ou
octobre j'étais à l'école à
saint-nicolas digne il n'y a pas eu
cette journée ce jour-là à la mort de
serre dans une minute de silence à
l'école mais vraiment 24 heures dessus
en télé nous avons pratiquement rien
fait les professeurs et les élèves
étaient absolument incapable de
travailler et j'ai un autre souvenir
assez émouvant et drôle si vous voulez
qui me revient à l'esprit sur la mort de
serre dans le soir en rentrant chez moi
j'ai eu une altercation avec ma grand
mère parce que dans l'avion de marcel
cerdan il y avait une violoniste
française très c'est légal isabelle
ginette neveu et à l'époque je ne
connaissais pas du tout et ma grand mère
pleurait la mort de ginette ne moi je
pleurais la mort de marcel cerdan et
nous en sommes arrivés à nous attraper
verbalement assez durement avec ma grand
mère qui m'a valu une bonne gifle de sa
part parce que je défendrai la mort de
marcel cerdan vous souvenez de ces
propos je me souviens c'était sûr
borsalino je crois oui et je me souviens
très bien surtout du de l'automne 49 oui
vous avez été en dit vous voulez
peut-être encore amateur de boxe est ce
que comme les boxeurs je suis toujours
et ce comme les boxeurs vous craignez le
combat de trop à ça je l' ai beaucoup
d'annoncés gelé toujours des matières
oui bien sûr lequel il a été et nous
sort le film de trop en ce qui me
concerne et c'est pour ça que j'ai
déclaré d'ailleurs j'ai votre nom que
j'ai inventé le film a donc vous arrêter
le cinéma mais c'était quoi le combat
trop là le combat de trop c'est le film
de trop je ne veux pas faire ce film de
trop vous n'avez pas encore fait mais
justement je ne le ferai pas vous ne
pourrez pas très bien alors peut-être un
mot d'une affaire dont on a un peu parlé
qui a plutôt fait la une des faits
divers
vous avez demandé à la justice
d'interdire en tout cas provisoirement
sur un synopsis un niveau concernant qui
devait raconter un peu votre vie privée
l' affaire touche rafa sera jugée au
fond eu le 14 octobre
j'aurai un peu comprendre votre réaction
d'abord en général vous ignorez un peu
ce que l'on dit de vous oui je crois je
vais vous décevoir
béatrice schönberg parce que depuis le
12 août je ne me suis jamais manifesté
sur cette affaire ce qui n'est pas le
cas de mes adversaires que n'ont pas eu
cette retenue et qui se sont sacrément
l'émission froid ni à chaud je n'y
répondrai pas parce que justement
j'attends ce 14 octobre le jugement sur
le fond je suis tout à fait serein et
j'ai tout à fait confiance dans la
justice et je m'exprimerai après le
jugement sur le fond du 14 octobre sur
le pourquoi de ce alors je serai en
d'asservir je vous rendez vous après le
14 octobre
peut-être une dernière question mais
alors là retour retour à la pièce tous
les deux qu'est ce que vous souhaiteriez
que le public retienne en sortant de
cette pièce au soir de la première ou d
autres présentations n'a eu l'autre
c'était même jeu moi j'ai pas vécu en
corse que lui a déjà vécu pendant cinq
fois et c'est mais en lisant cette pièce
en la répétant je sens qu'il ya une
telle charge d'émotion qu'on a on sort
et on a envie de rester dans cette
émotion et j'espère que le public qui va
venir nous voir à la de lancer moi aussi
la même chose souhaite simplement que le
public soit heureux et que nous remercie
d'être venus merci en tout cas à tous
d'être venus à dernier sujet pour
refermer ce journal à florence deuxième
biennale de la mode avec pour thème
cette année le mariage réussi de la
couture et du cinéma les palets
florentin pour écrin et cendrillon entre
carrosse en citrouille pour une nouvelle
version rajeunie
nicole cornu langlois dominique bonnet
le lien entre les héros romantique du
titanic
le panache de cyrano de bergerac et les
splendeurs du dernier rang coureur n'est
pas évident et pourtant la biennale de
florence les a réunies car tous ces
films ont en commun des oscars pour
leurs costumes
c'est l'une des expositions du thème
mode et cinéma dans les palais du prato
de florence derrière ces façades on
retrouve l'insouciance du jardin des
physiques ontinyent ou le futurisme du
prochain film de binz marne à travers le
lien mode cinéma on voit tous les jours
de la mode cinéma et du cinéma avant
laboeuf finalement parce que ça permet
de créer beaucoup plus parce que c'est
plus ouvert parce que cette culture
populaire pendant tout près du célèbre
pont et vecchio envahie par les
touristes
on entre dans le palais spinney ferroni
musée de la chaussure et c'est un autre
monde avec la légendaire pantoufles de
cendrillon héroïne toujours d'actualité
qui inspire les couturiers comme
galliano viviane les sous-doués emmanuel
ungaro pour la 40e version ever after
deux ans dit nantes chacun il est un peu
ce qu'il porte en lui et chacun il mais
surtout le mister les genres ayant est
mr total au fond c'est une somme ne sera
pas d'une histoire du midi l'un
territoire de princesse
pas tellement dans ce film car drew
barrymore donne un coup de jeune et
d'audace à ce costume traditionnel et à
cette époustouflante pantoufles fait
main objet de fétichisme érotique pour
le prince je ne porterai pas cela dans
la vie dit elle c'est trop brillant ça
ne va avec rien dans ma garde-robe
personnel et pourtant pour l'avant
première mondiale du film elle arborait
une tenue de conte de fées tout comme
angela houston qui joue la marâtre mais
c'était pour le bal de cendrillon un bal
où la mode rejoignez le cinéma et la
réalité dépasse la fiction se termine ce
journal je vous rappelle les principaux
titres aux antilles la guadeloupe se
barricade dans la tente de l'ouragan
george hill en apprend que 170
sauveteurs de la sécurité civile ont
quitté la france pour les antilles après
la décision du conseil régional de
l'ordre de relaxer un médecin ayant
pratiqué l'euthanasie le débat sur la
mort douce et réouvert dans un instant
la météo nathalie rihouet à 20h50 la
série urgences demain soir vous
retrouverez claude sérillon je vous
remercie de votre attention excellente
soirée sur france 2
non